[Music]
Friday called from Tom Curren written
while events were unfolding regarding
the solicitation of prostitution charges
against Patriots owner Robert Kraft Tom
says did it didn't do it who knows right
now the bottom line is the country's
most recognizable 77 year old
multi-billionaire was at the very least
at the wrong place at the wrong time and
you know what even if he just stopped in
to ask directions and gave somebody 20
dollars for their assistance nobody's
really going to care or remember that's
again our good buddy Tom Curren joining
us from Puerto Rico by phone Tom what
are you doing in Puerto Rico I'm glad
you asked the McCurdy's Devon and Jayson
McCrory are on a goodwill tour that the
folks here in Puerto Rico asked them to
come down then they said she want to
bring somebody in the media bring them
to the rebuilding from Hurricane Maria
and they wanted to send out the message
but they are open for business I'm
staying at the Intercontinental San Juan
the boys did a clinic over the weekend
at the Roberto Clemente Sports City work
is important they play a lot of football
down here believe it or not they work
2016 playing American football Saturday
in February in the heat and the cells
were over there and they they observe
they ran a clinic afterwards so it's
been a good weekend and and really the
island has rebounded nicely so if thank
you for giving me the chance to get that
message out there for these people
because it's it's a hell of a place
these people real nice and you know an
item of news that kind of got superseded
by everything that happened on Friday
Devin McCourty making it clear on
Thursday that he is going to come back
that's big for the Patriots and Jason
McCord he wants to stay with the
Patriots but when you consider how they
played last year the played the Jason
McCord he made in Super Bowl 53 if those
two guys stay with the Patriots that's
very good from a football standpoint
100% and the interesting thing is
Jason's a free agent the way he played
will certainly you know create a little
bit of buzz around him he did say his
first choices stay here but I think also
it is a business you're not going to
play for as title I used to say I'm not
going to come up there and play for a
nickel bill so
he could certainly have offers elsewhere
and it might have to be a decision for
him if the Patriots do say yeah we know
you want to stay here so we're gonna
lowball you give me your reaction when
you first saw the news on Friday I had
to like refocus my eyes three or four
times because I thought wait a minute
what is this is this a joke if somebody
trying to be funny and then I realized
this is real the the news that Robert
Kraft was charged with two counts of
soliciting prostitution in Florida your
thoughts when you first saw it and when
you first realized that that it was real
that it had happened my first
inclination was what what are you doing
I mean I understand
to a degree keeping it young
entertaining vibrant and alive you know
I mean he's at the Oscars over the
weekend but there are times when Robert
is out there a little too much I mean
his dance with Hardy be at the Super
Bowl and it's fun and it's but there are
times when I say is that really age
appropriate and where was someone in his
entourage whether it be a security
person I mean I'm sure he's not
unaccompanied when he's in in West Palm
Beach is probably someone with him say
this really is a horrible idea mr. Kraft
so that that to me was my reaction
because there is so much at stake
there's so much at stake when you're a
person like that and he is a good person
but you certainly cede the moral high
ground on a lot of issues
you certainly are going to cede some
ability to have people listen to what
you say when you have something that's
an embarrassing event and again it's not
something that rises to the level and
you don't let it play out and certainly
not a non-serious situation especially
when we find out what the women involved
in that particular establishment what
the what they were under whether they
were there voluntarily or not but it
just doesn't make any sense to you but
the other interesting thing like do is
covering this team over the course of
time for whatever reason the number of
things that happen here you're never
really surprised either when something
completely off the radar emerge you say
oh well this will be something we'll be
covering for the next few months why and
here's the thing right there's been a
categorical denial issued by the
Patriots on behalf of Robert Kraft and
and for now it is simply a charge and if
he wants to he could fight this thing
tooth and nail I mean he could put
together a team of lawyers that that
that tears the thing apart that
ultimately gets an exoneration if he
really wants to spend the time and the
money necessary to do it do we know at
this point other than that categorical
denial will this be something that
quietly gets resolved or will he fight
and spend and do everything he has to do
to prove that he didn't do it
as of Friday and throughout the weekend
the legal team has been assembled and
they're trying to figure out exactly
what they'll do now the legal system
down there the police and the people
running the operation said that they do
have video so it's going to make it a
hell of a lot more difficult for him to
say yeah wasn't me if there's video of
him not only entering but also having
any kinds of activities while he's in
there so their hope was that this would
perhaps be able to be dismissed then
that was their hope on Friday that you
know it could quietly go away but if
there's video I think it'll make it a
hell of a lot more difficult especially
if you've run a sting 25 other
individuals are involved and the most
high-profile one has his charges
dismissed after the police chief says we
have video so they've almost got to
follow through as much as they can down
in West Palm Beach Jupiter and if there
is any legal responsibility ultimately
imposed on Robert Kraft the Commissioner
the NFL Roger Goodell will have to do
something we've seen Jim Irsay get
suspended for operating a vehicle
under the influence and also find
$500,000 now for some teams the
suspension of an owner would matter does
the suspect craft eventually is
suspended and her say was suspended six
games to start the season a few years
ago if Robert Kraft gets suspended six
games to start the season if that's how
this plays out does that have any impact
whatsoever on the team on the way a
place on the field I don't think it has
I don't think it will register at all I
don't think it would register really
even in the upper reaches I mean
certainly he's an impactful guy he's an
important guy and he's involved still
Jonathan of course is involved as well
but the football is run by Bill
Belichick and Nick Caesarea and you know
I spoke to the McCurdy's about this as
well and they said they're so bill is so
adept at focusing players on look that's
not your job
not your job to comment on something
that doesn't involve you those whoever's
involved in it will have it resolved
itself I mean we can go back through the
annals from Josh Gordon this past year
to deflate gate to Julian Edelman
suspension to the unbelievable
controversy and tragedy of the Aaron
Hernandez situation so Tedy Bruschi
stroke I mean to Spygate this team
navigates those things because they
ignore them they don't ignore them when
they're off the field when it comes time
to go into the office people aren't
sitting around the water cooler and
talking about can you believe what
happened mr. Kraft and you know that's a
great point the the the thing that Bill
Belichick has done better than any coach
really in NFL history and especially
modern history where there are so many
potential distractions disruptions and
and things that can take away from what
you're trying to get your team to do
which is focus on the task at hand
Belichick has been able to keep his team
focused on what's in front and forget
anything else that's going on around the
team anything else that's happened in
the past anything else that may be
irrelevant to football focus on what you
need to do next and if there's any team
out there that is best suited to just
shrug at something like this it is the
Patriots it's bizarre I mean we would
talk
as we read into it about the Antonio
Brown I said I was gonna ask me about
Antonia Brown and that's the interesting
thing because every fiber of me says
they wouldn't want to Antonio Brown why
would they want him and then of course
Pittsburg resistant to the idea of
trading him here but how many times over
the course of the years has the most
spoken above player available ended up
being signed by the Patriots where it's
you know otro Cinco or Albert
Haynesworth or Tim Tebow Randy Moss over
the course of time they they do make the
splash signings that make you know
they're really gonna sign him and then
more often than not not always but more
often than not it works out pretty well
do you think they will make a play for
Antonio Brown I don't because he wants
that new money and that's why I think to
the Odell Beckham situation is so
difficult for me to wrap my mind around
to because the money that he is making I
mean Bill Belichick has looked at wide
receivers over the course of time as
being interchangeable type players even
Randy Moss was here he had to fight for
the extension that he got and eventually
that's what drove him out of town as he
felt he was underpaid relative to what
he brought to the team they don't pay
for wide receivers they don't look at
them necessarily as totally
interchangeable but the array of skills
that outside the Seavers bring that
caused them to make the money they do
are not as highly valued in New England
look they cut loose Brandon cooks who
was a thousand-yard 73 catch guy for
them and they had no real replacement in
house for him in 2018 and mainly because
they had to pay him eight million
dollars and have to be a free agent at
the end of the year so that's why I have
a hard time thinking about the Antonio
Brown or Odell Beckham being signed here
but if you can get Ono Beckham jr. for
less than twelve million dollars a year
over five years if you could do that you
can Herot the remaining contract because
the John's paid him 20 million out of
the gates it's under 60 million for the
final five years that's not a bad deal
Frodo Beckham jr. if you could get that
and it's a great point what it also
brings into focus though is someone like
Rob Gronkowski so Gronk is working on a
deal now that was great at the beginning
sucks now and as a result if you bring
Odell Beckham in at 12 million dollars a
year and Gronk is making nine it's just
gonna agitate him even further so
whether or not he comes back and I have
a greater feeling that he might be back
than I did you know toward the end of
the season but there's your pay
structure in New England it's out of
whack you're gonna pay Odell Beckham
twelve million dollars and doing
elements for well five that to me it's
for the Patriots over the course of time
to get players to swallow the pay
structure that is out of whack at times
for them when other guys on the team are
making more money like the way now it's
making six million dollars that's more
than Julian Edelman makes so it's that
would be another thing that they would
have to concur if they did bring a
player in like that alright Tom hey I
gotta run but he appreciates him of your
time travel site defendant will talk to
you soon
thank you there he is Tom Curren
NBC Sports Boston and you know I think
it may make sense to link Gronk to obj
because if Gronk is gone maybe you would
be more inclined to revisit the effort
to try to get odo Beckham jr. something
the Patriots did last year according to
our own Chris Sims who will be joining
us later this week in Indianapolis
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports